c'est toujours aussi miliana c'est
incroyable merci le temps ne peut rien
contre vous le ministre est bien placé
le plus célibataire de tous les
ministres du gouvernement jospin pour
moi c'est un très grand plaisir de tous
côtés de mario been on est très heureux
de l'accueillir ce soir je suis pas
encore malheureusement
jaubert a tourné avec les plus grands
acteurs français piccoli belmondo noir
et depardieu trintignant 28 aura les
plus grands acteurs étrangers kirk
douglas anthony perkins orson welles
charles bronson et même un petit bout de
film avec richard burton si avec
cosmatos
oui mais pas grand chose à faire non
mais bon vous avez tourné avec les plus
grands réalisateurs mal godard chabrol
rappeneau clément pialat
on se souvient de vous dans des films
comme les mariés de l'an ii de rappeneau
nous ne vieillirons pas ensemble de cas
la métairie de toi lui de clément non
mais voilà non mais c'est quand même une
énorme carrière quoi et en étant plus
content de vous recevoir ce soir marc et
alors tous qu évidemment c'est vrai
votre look et les yeux bleus en amendes
gérard dépit des taches de rousseur
paris taches de rousseur au départ pour
marine jobert c'était un petit peu un
complexe quand vous étiez enfant et puis
vous avez eu cet accident de voiture
avec une cicatrice de 13 cm sur le
visage et finalement ça vous a aidé
parce que vous des signes et des taches
de rousseur au crayon et sa masquer un
petit peu là la cicatrice oui c'est vrai
il s'est vraiment cette chose c'est vrai
j'ai eu cet accident j'ai traversé le
pare brise et et on m'a fait un ponçage
et sa enlever tous les toutes les tâches
de rousseur d'un côté il fallait donc
équilibré et je mens rajouter
voilà
alors depuis 88 vous écrivez et vous
prêtez votre voix des contes pour
enfants et vous dites qu à force
d'inventer des histoires pour vos filets
de fameuses jumelles ce comme denise
fabre à des jumelles un jour en vacances
vous êtes dit ça y est j'y vais et puis
vous avez commencé à écrire et depuis
vous avez adapté 60 comptes classiques
et 13 création originale sur des idées à
vous et vous avez vendu six millions de
livres et de cd
lait du blé
ça va bah oui visite munichois un jour
comme ça j'ai voulu écrire ses comptes
en vacances c'est vrai comme on fait des
photos pour garder des souvenirs de
cette période magique merveilleuse et
puis c'est vrai que j'ai éprouvé
beaucoup de plaisir à le faire et puis
des des amis en ont parlé à des éditeurs
et si l'on écoute et enfin l'uimm on en
demandait d'autres et je vois là c'est
parti ça a très bien marché alors
aujourd'hui vous publier l'arbre qui
pleure c'est un c'est un dessin animé
c'est la première fois d'ailleurs quand
vos comptes et est adapté en dessin
animé alors vous savez comment on fait
mais si vous allez voir laurent tu lui
explique
c'est très con mais ils vont bien le
truc après
alors c'est comme ça
un matin il se passait des choses très
étranges
des choses qui allait tout changer dans
la vie du petit pierre jusque là la
chance ne lui avait pas beaucoup souri
on peut même dire qu'elle m'avait
carrément fait la grimace imaginez à
trois ans et par an meurent dans un
accident
je vais écouter ça maintenant de mathan
malveillants je pense que ça ne mettra
vraiment de la
vie
[Applaudissements]
oui
s'appelait charge aubert
il faisait quoi militaire unités
militaires
et votre mère s'appelait eliane azoulay
et vous est l'aînée de cinq enfants est
votre première vocation c'est un peu
comme sandrine bonnaire votre vocation
ses coiffeuses oui je crois fait toutes
les
les voisines samedi et qui habitait dans
mon immeuble j'avais 12 qu'à 13 ans
j'aimais bien ça ouais ouais square pour
steevy sont
alors moins drôle un jour vous quittez
lg et votre père est muté à dijon
effectivement c'est vrai qu'en plus bon
votre père c'est comme une éducation
assez sévère un outil assez à l'époque
un peu timide et complexé mal dans votre
peau longwy
mon père était de l'assistance publique
et il est rentré dans l'armée c'était
pour lui déjà formidable c'est vrai
qu'il a eu une enfance plutôt difficile
c'est rigide et il a cru enfin moi
l'aîné
qu'il fallait me lever un peu comme ça
donc ce n'était pas facile mais pas
facile heureusement vous aviez une
échappatoire et c'était d'ailleurs votre
seule échappatoire c'est le théâtre
amateur du cercle militaire c'est à dire
que votre foi a été membre de ce théâtre
amateur et comme c'était l'armée de
votre père a laissé faire finalement oui
voilà c'est une goutte bol ça tient à
l'évocation quand même c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est fou qui reviendra bah oui
donc voilà répétition représentation de
vienne pour vous une excuse un petit peu
pour fuir le sortant henri cain d sinon
il va sortir alors après vous vous entré
au conservatoire de dijon on sortait
avec le premier prix oui mais voilà et
alors là un jour huppert vous dis
maintenant on va à madagascar non non
vous montez appareils pour monter à
paris bon vous entré au conservatoire
pendant un an et demi vous êtes obligé
de quitter pour des raisons financières
non c'est pas tout à fait ça c'est que
je devais partir en tournée avec yves
montand dans des clones par milliers et
à l'époque je crois même maintenant
encore on nous interdit on peut pas
quitter le conservatoire c'est un kit on
quitte définitivement et je bouge je
veux tu avais tellement envie de partir
en tournée avec yves montand oui dégaine
faciliter votre deuxième qui est la
première c'était le timide au palais en
effectivement après des clowns par
milliers et puis ensuite vous fait vos
débuts au cinéma avec godard qui vous
cast dans masculin féminin avec jean
pierre léaud et chantal goya ça s'est
pas bien passé avec godard c'était mon
premier rôle alors j'imagine et qui ne
contacte qui vous vient à voir avec un
metteur en scène comment on aurait parlé
du personnage doit mener ce qui faisait
pourquoi il faisait certaines choses lui
voulait rien nous dire tu vas là là tu
pose pas de question et c'est tout
j'étais déçu certains cas très triste
ouais en tous les cas votre carrière est
lancée alors j'ai fait la carrière dont
on a parlé est votre seul regret c'est
d'avoir refusé césar et rosalie dont le
rôle est a finalement été interprétée
par romy schneider pourquoi vous les
refuser à ces prêts tout à fait comme ça
que ça s'est passé je venais de tourner
le passager de la pluie il fallait que
je le présente en amérique
je suis parti donc là bas et avant de
partir sautez me fais lire
et je lui dis bon ben oui pourquoi pas
mais l'euro est quand même il pourra pas
être un petit peu étoffés
d'accord oui bon d'accord on va l'étoffé
très bien je pars et quand je reviens je
l'appelle tout de suite et il me dit je
les fais lire arômes il aime beaucoup
c'est tout moi je suis très fier j'ai
rien dis ouais mais qu'est-ce que j'ai
eu mal ouais je lui parlais de mon
voyage mammeri jeu grand raid votre
carrière ah ouais alors bon là vous
allez énorme star fait cinq films par an
et beaucoup d'argent par film et vous
tailler un petit peu faut dire la vérité
dans le métier une réputation dans mr 2
parce que vous pensez que le métier
paresseux c'est à vous reprocher un peu
le laisser-aller des des scénaristes
enfin vous êtes
c'est l'éducation de papa ça non par
rapport à votre père vous trouviez tout
le monde assez paresseux
oui et aussi le manque d'assurance que
j'ai toujours times a pas beaucoup qui
tu es mais j'avais tout le temps je ne
comprenais pas qu'on puisse qu'on ne
fasse pas le maximum alors que c'était
possible et à chaque fois le métier
d'acteur enfin dans cinéman importe que
c'est on est des maillons de la chaîne
et on dépend tellement des autres et
quand on voit que le maximum n'est pas
fait on est très malheureux que
peut-être que je n'avais pas la
diplomatie qu'il fallait pour exprimer
les choses si au fond de ma mairie au
fond vous aviez besoin d'être d'être
assurée et puis peut-être personnes qui
arrivent à vous rassurer non c'est ça
c'est ça sûrement vous étiez dans le
désarroi l'insécurité non mais c'est
vrai qu'ils vivent à ceux proposés dans
deux minutes
tu le connais bien je te vois venir
alors finalement on pourrait dire que le
rôle le plus difficile pour vous dans
votre vie c'était celui de star parce
que vous n'êtes pas prenez pas pour une
star quoi oui je me sentais pas prête
j'étais peut-être un propulser un peu
rapidement et je me sente je me sentais
démunis
bagage culturel affectif et et au lieu
de jouir de cette merveilleuse chose qui
m'arrivait j'étais au rez et
terriblement angoissée ouais enfin si
vous en aviez joué vous aurez peut-être
pas fait la même carrière non plus un
juge
de semer chez les données en tous les
cas vous mettez votre carrière en
sourdine pour vous occuper de vos filles
le le métier d'actrice passe un peu au
second plan
parce que vous dites c'est pas possible
pour moi et des jupes des filles qui
font tout vous vous dites c'est pas
possible pour moi de faire la fois
maman actrice amoureuse
donc vous pouvez pas tout assurer que
les filles de maintenance et je veux
tout comme le titre du fameux film
derrière vous non j'aurais bien aimé
être capable de tout mais je
savais que j'en étais capable
et non il faut dire aussi que j'avais eu
la chance d'avoir tout ça derrière si
j'avais été au début de ma carrière
franchement qu'on me dise voilà tu
choisis parce que tu en es pas capable
je sais pas si j'aurais pris cette
décision il faut dire aussi que votre
jeu pas si à l'époque j'étais mariée
mais walter greene
il a insisté pour les enfants
quatre fois par jour et vous en parlez
donc à un moment où on veut et craquer
quoi
d'où vous savez tout ça je n'en mets
s'il n'avait pas été là maintenant je
vous aurais pas c'est ce que je vais
vous entendre dire non non c'est vrai je
vous ai un peu forcé la main oui il ya
beaucoup insisté et c'est vrai quand je
suis qui n'avait 2 pas pu juger pas
hésité là bas deux points de chance
c'est que c'est réglé comme ça au moins
c'est à dire nos amis téléspectateurs
qui était un chirurgien dentiste walter
greene et donc je vous a fait deux
jumelles eva et johan qu'on appelle joy
alors pourquoi elle se ressemble si peu
vos jumelles je sais pas
si fausse jumelle la wii sur 100 m mais
pas du tout un point et une qui
ressemble à vous bb mais l'autre
qu'elles sont pas nés la même année non
et alors un jour alors que vous avez
arrêté le métier disons dans les grandes
largeurs c'est votre fille eva qui s'y
met et elle s'inscrit à l'école à une
école de théâtre et aujourd'hui voilà
c'est ça qui est formidable aujourd'hui
elle débute dans jalousie en trois facs
au petit théâtre de paris hélas
voilà on viendra conter la vie de maman
oui toute l'histoire de maman vous
saviez tout quand même pas tous pas tout
est langage des choses ah bon ouais mais
très jolie aussi cette famille vous êtes
dans jalousie en trois factions que les
deux jumelles ne se ressemblent pas
dire qu'on est pas née la même année
alors jalousie en trois facs d'esther
villard mise en scène de didier long
avec dominique labourier isabelle
gélinas et vous au petit théâtre de
paris comme je les dis donc je vais
faire le pitch de plus simple ouais les
gens aiment bien quand le pitch alors
donc ces trois femmes qui tourne autour
du même homme
qui n'est qu'évoquer on voit jamais le
mec habite à trois étages différents
d'un même immeuble et elle communique
par fax voilà alors vous êtes la jeune
iris
très détaché avec un peu de recul comme
ça de distance sur les choses
bouddhistes nous expliquer au début de
la pièce que la jalousie est inutile que
ça rien que c'est ridicule et évidemment
vous tombez à votre tour dans le panneau
c'est ça
vous découvrez malgré vous la jalousie
et vous devenez à ce moment là c'est
vulnérables assez agressive voire animal
oui comme les deux autres oui oui on
connaît toutes les trois les mêmes
palier
au fond ça commence par hélène ensuite
par rihanna et ensuite par mois et on a
toutes les trois des âges différents et
on connaît de la jalousie de différentes
manières selon une personnalité
et donc moi au début donc je suis très
bout d'istres très très zen très calme
et puis après bon bah je tombe dans le
panneau plus tout jeune et donc bas et
c'est vrai que je suis celle qu en fait
qui souffrent le plus je crois les
autres ont déjà une certaine maturité
par rapport à l'existence d'un certain
recul et c'est vrai que donc je suis la
seule à vraiment pas à faire une
tentative de suicide tout ça
vous été choisi par 1060 candidate oui
je serai contente marne bah ouais ouais
avant d'entrer en scène il ya des jours
c'est agréable et des jours pas vous dit
certaines fois on a l'impression d'aller
à l'échafaud et d'autres fois d'aller
vers dieu était avec ça c'est un jour
sur deux ou comment ça se passe
on al impression un peu de plongée dans
une piscine d'eau froide en fait j'ai la
chair de poule on est toutes les trois
en train de faire la ronde l'a enfin
train de se concentrer et c'est vrai
qu'on a toutes les preuves un peu le
trac mais c'est sûr c'est sûr sonne
quand même on est avec du tout le temps
avec dieu je crois c'est aller chafouk
en avant de rentrer ouais c'est déjà
faux avant et puis après on va l'arrêter
vous l'avez vu combien de fois marais de
la pièce 7 cette fois
et
pourquoi est ce que vous n'avez pas
compris
je suis tellement contente c'est vrai
qu'elle est réussie tout seul parce que
c'est bon elle a vraiment passé ces
auditions elle a été choisie et si tu as
un rôle difficile elle a une chance
formidable c'est une pièce magnifique
les deux partenaires mais vraiment
magnifique c'est une chance formidable
un grand metteur en scène et la de
l'avoir la
fermette j'ai pas vu la pièce mais c'est
ça fait partie des pièces dont le bouche
à oreille dans paris et dire que moi
tout le monde me parle de cette pièce et
je vais couvrir des lavoirs pas ce
qu'est vraiment le bouche à oreille est
merveilleux ces jalousies en trois facs
au petit théâtre de paris je devrais pas
votre soeur est jalouse de vous
aubin comme toute seule je pense mais là
elle est très contents pour moi un bon
feeling a beaucoup surpris au début elle
a écouté mes interviews sur les radios
elle suit tous les articles non je suis
très touchée en fait ses débuts quand
vous faisiez des cours est tous assez
intéressé pas trop bill que vous êtes
sur scène seul coup un
mail réagi très très bien mais elle fait
quoi cette soeur cette soeur elle fait
des études de commerce qu'ils étaient
indifférents oui c'est dommage que ça
part vraiment ressemblante la jumelle
parce que les dents mieux mais non les
soirs voulant réellement vous n'en voyez
c'est génial asseoir sur deux je sais
pas si ça lui plairait mais quand vous
étiez enfant marlène vous a quand même
éloigné du milieu du showbiz ne voyez
pas trop de stars vous étiez assez
protégé de samedi tout n'est jamais allé
les tournages moins payés dans milieu
jamais fait des rencontres jamais dans
les squares et tout ça donc non non et
en plus comme sa carrière avait un peu
ralenti vous en faites vous saviez pas
que tu es aussi c'est l'aide d'une
certaine façon ah non non je la voyais
vraiment comme quelqu'un de bon et très
protégés mauvais un cocon un port de la
réalité donc c'est vrai que ça s'est
passé pas isabelle huppert qui est
toujours travail
oui beaucoup de dentiste adore vous dans
teen star
je vais pas assez souvent
alors dites moi vous allez jouer toutes
les deux sur scène un jour non
ça serait drôle à
vous une fille très sérieuse à vous trop
sage trop sage ça c'est vraiment j'ai
l'impression de vivre maintenant faim
depuis que je joue vous n'êtes pas trop
boîte de nuit et tout ça pas du tout pas
du tout je suis très vieille mémé qui
écoutent de la musique classique sur mon
lit non non pas du tout mais j'aime
beaucoup ce n'est pas demain
la musique classique des classiques le
côté très sérieux sérieux on va aller à
c'est
maintenant
ça va
j'ai ce terminal est donc petit air de
paris
alain marois un truc terrible horrible
je vous jure
non non pas un non je serai à n'ont pas
dit non non je pourrais pas là je ferai
pas pu faire pire j'ai fait la vie très
difficile c'est une interview débutants
tiens je vais faire comme si j'étais moi
même un journaliste débutant et je vais
vous poser les questions que pose des
journalistes débutants très compliqué on
ne bouge pas
non
si vous êtes joker
c'est pierre moscovici qui répond
j'avais un ministre comme joker quand
même plaignez vous je suis très fier
alors par exemple les débutants ils
disent être gardées c'est quoi votre
pièce
sa jalousie trois facs est ce que vous
pensez être un modèle pour ceux qui vous
aident bien
j'ai pas encore beaucoup d'admirateurs
l'échec vous y pensez tout le temps
chaque seconde trop d'ailleurs
avez vous besoin de vous imprégner de
votre personnage avant de l'interpréter
oui oui j'essaie de me concentrer avant
d'entrer sur scène et de m'envoyer les
informations nécessaires pour les
personnages on continua t avec débutants
quel est le message de la pièce
la jalousie
est un moyen d'excitation
pour entretenir le couple
iris c'est un peu de vous où beaucoup de
vous
mais ça vous vous habituez vous à des
journalistes débutants et naples 1
1 pour beaucoup ouais vous manger avant
ou après la pièce après
vous avez un plan de carrière
oui je contourner avec spielberg
on verra après 1 quels conseils
donneriez-vous une débutante
de pas se laisser bouffer par le regard
des autres et de faire vraiment ce qu'on
a envie d'être d'être très libre vous
répondez d'une façon très pro une
question débutants voilà exactement
on voudrait être comme ça
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux